youtube community free soldier i
completely agree with you the most
important thing we can do in 2008 and
every other year is to make sure we
invest in our children really we invest
in all human beings because you're
absolutely right when people are
educated when they have skills and
abilities this world becomes a much
better place we have a responsibility I
think to do that for our children to as
we in our us parlance say leave no child
behind that means that every single kid
of every zip code every race and every
community has to have the opportunities
to be successful in this world the other
thing I would say to young people is
make sure you invest in yourself invest
in your own education take
responsibility for yourself get the
opportunities at your local community
college and in your public schools so
that you can be a true global
participant and I would also say that
every person needs to know that they can
make a difference they can contribute
they can give back they can save a life
they can teach a child they can be a
good mom or dad so free soldier you go